Has anyone had any success taking oral B-17 or amygdala possibly in high doses?
I should have pulled up a picture of this. We have a number of people that tested well for B-17.
We use the apricot, our brand B-17. It comes in two formulas.
One is a 500 milligram per capsule formula, and one is a 100 milligram per capsule formula.
Now, high doses depends on how you define that.
Typically, you depend on your weight, but let's say your body weight is 125 pounds.
The maximum dose you'd really go is, and you'd have to work up to this dose,
it would be probably three to four 500 milligram capsules per day.
Now, I know there's some clinics that go much higher than that, but they typically do that for a shorter period of time.
Some people don't tolerate super high doses of B-17.
So, I always suggest you start slow with a lower dose to begin with, and then work up.
We've had one person, and it was actually a staff person a number of years ago that took nine or ten of them at one time.
I have no idea why, and they got a really bad headache, and they felt sick and had to lay down and flush them with water,
and it took about three hours to pass, so they felt better, but they learned a lesson not to overdose on that.
It's very powerful, and it can make you sick too, so you have to just be careful with your dosage, so you're not overdosing on that.